completely winning barely made that move
two seconds per minute he barely made
his move Rook takes G6 and he's dropping
all his Pawns
banking on the d-pawn The Last Hope for
bluebaum
yeah and then yeah the look is coming
from behind
Rook E8 no rook d8 and wait a second
still not totally over blue bomb
activating his Pawn
and bit it might have to give up his
Rook at the right moment for that pawn
[Music]
he's a little nervous but G6 still
winning
yes
in G5 that's it
oh
two seconds
he gets to H6
zigzagging around Rook at five draw Rook
at five
unbeatable you
buildable Rook takes up oh my God and
black will win the newly promoted Queen
[Music]
he had to go King D4 to stop Rook C5 and
black white will win
oh unbelievable
[Music]
no freaking way
I cannot believe what we have just
witnessed
there was a draw black had to go
anywhere but where he went he allowed
this bridge construction and if he had
gone up with his King it was an instant
drop
and now he will play Until The Bitter
End it is made
oh
the except Amber he cannot believe
and feed it through to the next land
what the drama foreign